when Denzel won the Academy Award it's  almost like an out-of-body experience  for me it was all out-of-body experience  just to be at the Academy Award what two  of my actors nominated you know you just  try not to expect to win anything you're  just happy to be there and when he won  in the room sort of erupted with the  applause and everything it was probably  the most exciting moment in my career so  far  I mean I'm it was the most exciting  moment in my career I'm very proud of it  I'll never forget it it's a great  feeling and it keeps me hungry to it you  know wanted want to do it again  I would love to see another actor of  mine with me get an Academy Award it's a  great feeling